gela tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su vari
organi state comunque che l'aveva già
fatto tipo un anno fa ricordo neanche
più forse anche di più comunque ragazzi
l'hanno aggiornato un casino e mi avete
chiesto tutti di rifarlo perché hanno
aggiunto cose siamo già partiti
associati a così proprio l'anno
aggiornato tipo a ecco pepe di natale
fantastico hanno aggiunto di versione
natalizia deve essere una figata
pazzesca tra l'altro cose da rubare
allora ragazzi stone gioco è un gioco
che bisogna rubare delle cose in una
casa per chi non lo conoscesse malavedo
di ficus e non so neanche come si prende
la roba pro ok
e vabbè cosa che cosa devo prendere che
non ho capito che non ho mai visto un
ladro con la lista della spesa che va a
rubare a casa ma c'è sempre una prima
volta fedeli sia un altro di natale che
figo provarlo lo stesso regalo anche se
l'albero mica l'albero intero proprio
fantastico lo lascio quadra blet madonna
quanta roba certa mi chiama hai fatto la
cena di natale zio madonna è la
mezzanotte un computer
posso prendere il largo nella lista
dallo zio lo presti perfetto ragazzi che
l'abbiamo 1
no no no no no no no no terra che è
perfetto
voi voi non conoscete il proprietario di
questa casa è un cantuccio troppo
incazzato che se lo vedo mi fa più paura
dello slam doormen altro no giuro
veramente pazzesco sta aprendo nuovi il
didietro eccolo che marino questo cosino
quello che posso prenderlo grazie
allarme volato al mouse tutto il resto
fantastico giorno al pranzo di man
chiama ucciso bello ok altro magari così
c'è il randomizzazione senso gli oggetti
sono messi a caso il suo posto c'è anche
la play posso prenderla plein ora play
il debutto di soft perfetto vediamo di
muovere il culo prima che torni con
deficiente tanto di cuocere non c'è la
saporta
è nuovo anche l'anno a giunta sta cosa
marte perfetto se non ucciderlo devono
la vita sarà vicino misano prenderla
fatemi vedere la bicicletta la
bicicletta rubata e dove cazzo l'ho
messa nella tasca con l'iphone lefons
iva e considerano questo non aperti
bruciare i salari sono l'aspetto più
preciso bello il quadro anche sono no
perché è un genio sono un [ __ ] tu non
entri più voglio vedere adesso mentre
stop non entrerà mai più nella vita fa
temi che come ho fatto prima
allora parties cas come ho fatto a
salire in quattro secondo non è anche
visto lo stronzo mai tradito sei stato
tu dia vita dai da anello di diamante
questo ho trovato è tornato già caccia
ha messo in seconda mica è natale fai un
po di festa che duri e mio dio va bene
abbiamo dato una facciata i soldi
profumo ho trovato che fai caso si fa un
ladro di un proforma beh dato non
entrerà mai quaden come cazzo ha fatto
entrare canguro poiché cazzo succede
sorella salta il pranzo maestro ho
chiuso
l'ho chiuso claudio bat ma devi morire
veramente l'ho chiuso è stato tragico
proprio non è così impossibile
grazie comunque a trovare di altro che
tanto rimasto rinchiuso il tizio con le
cuffie le mie cuffie salemi e poi non ho
capito perchè perchè è entrato un
canguro in calo e vieni che un canguro è
un proprietario di una casa cioè fammi
capire
teheran teheran perché questo tiene le
mazzette di soldi perché la caccia
mafiosi kami fatemi capire perché è un
perché cassaforte e non mi ricordano mai
la combinazione figura 52 49 per caso lo
è ma va ascolta zio ma non è che perché
insomma la caccia a dire lui no vero
senti ora che bello veramente è stato
tragico riuscire poi a [ __ ] come fatto
come hai fatto
no no no no no no canguro di merda
cangura di come ho fatto uscire per una
volta è già avanti è fatta mista piave
ho trovato una chiave la chiave dell
ufficio a microonde microonde microonde
volevo prenderlo perché devo provare un
micron non me lo chiedete ragazzi un
posto cetriolo qualcosa mi dice che non
lo usi per mangiare ma l'anello un
anello di diamante ovviamente messo in
garage che non mi serve tra l'altro
fantastico trovata un bank una sola in
croce silva e così silver qando silana
nar una candela di d'argento non l'ho
capita che cosa cerca and since pocket
watch hanno trovato ma è arrivato adesso
no raga ecco perché non ecco mi sembrava
strano che non era arrivato nessuno va a
franco aree chiude mi sembrava strano
meglio io io un po pazzo non ti
azzardare avvicinarsi ti faccio superare
vivo da questo pupazzo demoniaco di
fendi che si sente un cazzo questo ma
respira suo uomo che il profumo digital
camera bianca bue silver che doveva esso
sì perché under si frega no no no no no
no no no no non ho mai visto cioè mi
sono chiuso non mi ha trovato non mai
trovato sarebbe la musica ne taglia di
sottofondo a parte gli scherzi
rea e molte lo prendi melilli no no no
no no no no no no no no nascita e
chiazza c'aveva gare di sei un morso
inutile stronzo si è ucciso con la sedia
non l'ho ucciso non l'ho ucciso c'era
già avevo quasi creduto a star da basta
non ce la fai a scendere cioè noi ce la
faccia ma affanculo
bye bye bye bye bye bye cosa devo
trovare cosa devo trovare no no no no
non mi avrai non mi avrà è vero facciamo
una cena di natale il panettone io ti do
panettone sappiamo lo champagne sapere
perché non hai la faccia
bravo no no no no no maps è ma allora
sei stronzo e offro bottiglie tool e
rompi pure io teleporto con tutta la mia
gentilezza e tool e rompi i remi mi
sapresti per favore dire dove trovare
una silver candlestick è un lingotto
d'oro dove ritieni ascoltami
e stato un piacere chiudi dove lo trovo
ecco l'ho trovata si riaccenda si fa ma
[ __ ] lampada da me tiene fermo e
lui no certo sto deficiente ma ancora
che mi fa ancora fatica ti tuoi niente
con la gente la privacy neanche no non
riusciva a entrare non riusciva le
mancava una tua madre brutta non ci
posso che non è possibile dai 9 a parte
gli scherzi e morire ma ancora lingotto
basso conti lingottino trovare istat non
ci son in gotti basta tablet tablet l'ho
trovato effetto stato anche ruttando se
vi interessa chiave posto sotto trovare
crisi ma spero questo ho trovato che non
era un crisma spalding partner nel
dubbio me ne vado perché sta arrivando
aperto si è coperto di qua non c'è
niente perché non c'ha manco li la
chiave perfetto 99 91 è la password
della cassaforte mi piace password della
madonna hanno visto che sono salito mi
chiudono la cassaforte mi chiudo stato
prendere mia lista cassaforte per farmi
che qua assordanti hacker propri
complimenti
harry potter visto che bravo nella mia
parola d'ordine è la madonna era qui lo
sapevo che era quindi meglio questo
gioco visto ciò con un cell audio ma mi
chiama fa una cag a quando mi prende il
tizio mi ha visto mi ha visto mia vita
mi sono visto un anno
andrà mai non mi prenderà mai invece ma
presa bastardo chiuso cioè che culo devo
che spegne le luci svegli e lucidi nomi
meglio su in luce dei fatti regali
normati regali rubarti regalino
materiali anche don che l'albero si no
ma quanto ci hai messo a farlo tt stupro
anche la lì sopra di sopra che lo chiudo
se riesco se riesco a chiuderlo madonna
madonna vieni code entra qua dentro sto
vieni qui vieni co dove sei
dov'è ma perso allo semi quello seminato
di brutto ce la sto facendo riad rubare
la roba di natale prima che mi veda di
nuovo spegne le luci di merda dove si
spengono dove l'interruttore lista ecco
no ma visto mai visto non ha visto non
ha visto non ha visto perfetto dove la
luce stop ok
no no no no no no no no non lo
schiacciava schiacciano scherzava no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no non
ho mai visto
no bastardo bastardo ti chiudo melo pupi
questo per natale questo tutto nel pacco
per quanto mi riguarda poi state neanche
li chiudo la porta di noi rom non hanno
sbagliato io cazzo sbagliato con un
colino un regalone post ritratto di una
ragazza da trovare un ritratto di una
ragazza grazie mi spieghi che cosa cazzo
me ne faccio sosta sembra facile perché
so dove si trova la maggior parte agli
oggetti la bicicletta la bicicletta la
so e quindi a microonde perfetto
braccialetto sì sì l'ho trovato l'ho
trovato perfetto tvt motivo di impresa
che sono già quasi tutto io prendo
questo e lo ammetto sulle scale tipo
casinò tipo qui si vince che salto dai
perfetta che ci siamo computer di qua mi
guarda la passio nocciola passo si ho
capito sì l'ho trovata ecco perfetto
come live arcade
devo trovare
dov'è il corso per la password 83 26 un
38 eyeliner è veloce veloce si trattò 6
38 st rincon dopo la macchina per
paziente di merda mai
vai dai cazzo si ho trovato tutto
riuscirei ma 5
no è entrato [ __ ] anche un casino
i soldi in più che di tipo mi danno
punti quindi musica si dove ci ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ho fatto sì sì sì me lo
può più fare tutto padana spettacolo
vado a cercare che si faccia la
boccaccia e poi estro ma quando cazzo 60
40 mila dollari di cash fantastico la
festa lab e ladro professionista era
troppa roba non ho capito perché la
seconda volta ne è uscito un canguro se
qualcuno di voi me lo spiega è stato
fantastico ragazzi concluso qui perché
troppo fa troppo ridere ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto ma se il tasso
documento mi piace anche pace di
facebook che come noi video trovate la
descrizione sono servirsi di silenzio ci
vediamo il prossimo video la ragazza